bienvenue sur des modèles tv pour suivre
donc la suite de cette finale du
championnat du monde 2015 championnat du
monde féminin entre natalia pogo nina et
maria nous y trouve donc mariano situe
qu'à pris l'avantagé dans cette finale
en ayant gagné la seconde partie match
en quatre parties donc il reste encore
deux parties à pogo nina pour revenir
dans le match
ce qu'elle a réussi à faire les trois
derniers matches précédents huitièmes
quarts et demi-finales natal est pourri
nina qui revient systématiquement et l'a
donc en finale est-ce qu'elle va pouvoir
revenir en tout cas elle a les blancs
dans cette troisième partie
à noter que si elle ne fait que nul et
bien il reste encore à il restera la
dernière partie pour pour égaliser et
poussé au tie break
et si elle perd par contre la partie la
dalle et pogo nina est bien le match est
fini mais oui parce que marié à musique
zouk mènera de deux points alors qu'il
ne restera qu'une seule partie à jouer
donc ce sera insuffisant titre mondial
en jeu donc
natalia pogonat la russe ouvre la partie
avec des quatre des cinq c4 c6
on revient à la slave qu'on en que l'on
a vu dans la première partie du match
jusqu'où les joueuses vont suivre cavale
et ses trois cavaliers le 6 2 3 1 c'est
classique dans les championnats du monde
comme ça que les joueurs travaillent sur
une ouverture précise et reviennent
dessus de 6 en tout cas elle n'a pas
peur marianne use it ou qu'elle a réussi
à faire une partie nulle finalement
assez logique dans la première partie
sans vraiment
risquer grand chose quels livres 3
qu'elle est 17ème ces deux food et si
c'est la même partie pour l'instant fou
détroit va bien falloir que pour rooney
n'a changé un moment donné puisque sinon
eh bien elle va de nouveau faire nul
sans tenter de pouvoir revenir au score
petit rock petit rock puis on prend feu
prend c'est toujours pareil que la
première des cinq faut deux à 6 on
l'avait déjà vu secours qui consolide b5
qui permet d'envisager des libérations
par c5 et la cavalier g5
alors voilà ça c'est nouveau ici dans la
dans la partie numéro un
elle avait joué tour des 1 créant un
vis-à-vis tour dames
donc ce qui rendait la poussée ces cinq
hommes tous délicate puisqu'en cas de
prison le vis-à-vis pouvait être gênant
mais ici elle joue un coup très
surprenante cavalli g5 bon pourquoi pas
alors que vais faire le cahier angers 5
bon déjà on voit qu'il ya la dame qui
peut viser hcdh mais tout ça est tenu
par le cavalier m6
ça libère aussi le plus bref peut-être
qu'on veut jouer f4 f5 essayer de briser
et bien se passer ce pion en russie 6 y
avoir un une ouverture sur la colonne f
par exemple et si les noirs jouent h si
ce qui est sans doute possible
eh bien peut-être on revient sur la case
e 4 en gagnant un temps sur le fou parce
qu'on attaque le fou voilà donc c'est un
coup pour mieux disposé ces pièces et
envisager pourquoi pas un sans doute une
poussée du pur f
ça peut être une possibilité un coup un
peu
ils ont un peu inattendu cette position
n'a pas encore développé le phocéen et
mais bon il faut bien effectivement
trouvé moyen d'améliorer ses pièces
comment on sort ce fou sur des deux bon
c'est pas forcément une place terrible
terrible donc il attend son heure ce fou
pour sortir et rejoue une pièce déjà
développé mais tout les pc sont
développés à part ce fou et qui bloque
aussi la tour 1 dames c'est cette alors
la batterie dame fou contre le clan h2
et la surprenant cette ouverture
regarder eux quatre voilà les blancs
n'ont pas peur eux quatre dents c'est ce
qu'on disait là se fout tout de suite
mais il a plus des airs déjà notamment
et devenir un étroit contrôle lecavalier
mais on donne un pion quoi et oui on
donne un pur mais pour prendre ce pion
il faut faire fou proche de ce que font
les noirs d'ailleurs ils le pren aient
après roy agen le problème est le
suivant ce fou et potentiellement en
danger puisque j'ai trois et il est pris
tout de suite c'est à dire qu'il va
falloir qu'ils sacrifient contre deux
autres pions mais on aura donné trois
pions pour une pièce bon notre
possibilité de l'enfermer c'est de jouer
f4f 4 le pion avec l'appui très bien
protégé par le phocéen et par la tour f
1 et se fout à des problèmes pour sortir
parce que où il va même s'il vit en g3
est con on peut continuer à l'attaqué
par exemple part d'amd trois tacles fou
si bien en h4 et bien simplement ce
cavalier revient en f3 et surtout n'a
pas de gaz puisque le pion et un f4 même
la classe gsm sera prise donc on peut
l'affirmer de deux façons une qui donne
deux bombes de pions mais l'autre qui
simplement qu'ils donnent papillon et là
on aura donné une pièce contre un pion
seul donc on pourrait se dire on enlève
le fou mais si on enlève le fou
maintenant où on le met c'est pas simple
si je le mets en d6 je prend 1,5
avec fourchette
fu cavaliers il reste l'envisagé le
couffo f4 qui est aussi intéressant la
fois f4 ses salaires moins dangereux
faux f4 en k 2 5
je peux envisager de prendre soin le fou
c'est un an avant soit le cavalier g5 et
ma foi bon après quelques échanges
possibles
ça a l'air de pouvoir être se tenir de
temps qu'on a pris un point on peut
envisager même de rendre un et peut-être
que c'est tenable bon mais les noirs
choisissent une voie beaucoup plus
tendue
regardez elle n'a pas peur marion nous y
tous les deux jouent à fond elle joue
pour le titre mondial
donc je joue c'est 5 voilà alors ces
cinq c'est la fameuse idée dont on avait
parlé
le fait qu'on ait joué à si c'était pour
surprotéger b5 ça permettait d'envisager
cette poussée à noter qu'en cas de prise
des noirs le vis-à-vis d'am-dam et en
faveur des noirs puisque la prise ici le
cas au lycée 3 sera immobilisé si on
prend et de plus la menace b4 gagnant
puisque la dame ces deux n'étant pas
protégés en cas de visas vis bien la
menace b4 obligera les blancs a trouvé
une parade
donc c'est 5 à l'air à l'air quand même
extrêmement pénible
donc les blancs réagissent de façon
dynamique e5
voilà donc sur ces 5 qui attaquent le
centre moi aussi j'attends qu'une pièce
et j'ai un tas de m2 parce que
lecavalier 6 et emprises et le fourrage
2 qui semblerait que les blondes gagnent
une pièce mais à quel prix puisque
maintenant regarder si les noirs
prennent en d4 avec le pion c est bien
le cas les c3 est perdue à cause du
vis-à-vis justement d'am dam dam
donc c'est ce que font de noir pas de
problème
c'est prend des quatre là les blancs
prennent le câble et m6 les noirs
prennent ils reprennent tout simplement
oui alors là qu'il a requis 6 mois je
pensais il aurait pu prendre ici en c3
mais ils sont pas prêts c'est toujours
pareil puisque ce cavalier s'il bouge
les dames sont perdus donc les noirs se
pressent pas ils veulent pas se faire
démolir l'europe doit oui d'autant
qu'ils aient une bonne assiette
c'est évident qu'il faut la cité c'est
que y'a dame prend 1,7 mat
un an après avoir pris le cavalier donc
on peut pas reprendre tout de suite en
c3 il faut d'abord jouer cavalier 6
heureusement oui bien sûr protège
simplement la case h7 donc là les blancs
maintenant ici jouent le coup qu'on
avait cité d'ailleurs tout à l'heure tu
as fait intéressant envers dsk rentré
lui jean ferme enfin le fou h 2 j'ai
gagné une pièce est une deuxième pièce
noire est en prise simplement les noirs
ont quand même une encore une pièce
apprend dans ces trois et ils peuvent
envisager en plus de ne pas se presser
pour l'apprendre puisqu'il ya toujours
ce vis-à-vis donc il joue au regard des
ses minions up fou j'ai trois normales
ou g3 j'enlève de la prise
mais on a vu que ce fou avait des
problèmes alors je joue pas tout reste
roi parce que si fou h 4 bat le cas il
est attaqué donc je perds un temps et je
pourrais pas prendre ce fou mais si je
joue le coup suivant des blanquetiers
très bien à double sens dam des trois
voilages attaque le fou de la dame et en
même temps je me sors de ce clou agen
qui a permis au noir de jouer des coups
autre que de prendre le cavalier donc là
la suite est quasiment forcé pour les
noirs qui vont perdre une pièce après
puis on prend ces trois d'un projet 3
incroyable donc c'est les noirs raconte
décidé de partir et leurs fous h2 et de
faire cette variante noir qui mène au
score dans le match et là regardez très
intéressant ce que font les noirs
notez h600 se presser voilà simplement
j'attaque le cavaly je me presse pas
d'envisager des prises en b2 et on va on
va en parler juste après six cavaliers
h33 pourquoi pas alors est ce qu'on
aurait pu jouer à notre courrier puis
bien sûr aussi joué le coup cavalier en
f3 peut-être que les blancs avaient peur
d'un coup comme cavalier ou 4 la dame
est attaquée et elle a pas beaucoup de
bonnes cases et le cavalier centraliser
le cavalier noir en jouant cavalier h3
en cas de cavaye 4 je peux jouer l'adhan
par exemple ou trois attaquants
lecavalier et donc je perds pas de temps
tandis que si je l'avais à me lecavalier
en f3 et bien sûr que la vie locale je
perds un temps je suis obligé de bouger
la dame est énorme
encore un coup derrière sans avoir de
casier attaquer donc ici cavalière 4
quand même bon il aurait pu jouer dans
2/3 pour gone in à bron le fait pas à le
jouer un coup
bond intéressant aussi ces dames 1 dames
un bon pourquoi pas
c'est vrai que la dame vin et quand même
aussi pas trop mal placé
alors on n'empêche pas le fou de sortir
et on peut menacer fou f3 qui attaquent
cavaliers avec la tour derrière c'est
pas c'est pas moins bon que d'un autre
et là les noirs ne prennent toujours pas
en b2 ils prennent pas un mais deux
pourquoi ils prennent pas en b2 parce
que les blancs et moins bien que les
noirs prennent en b2 parce que si les
noirs prennent ici sur cette case
simplement je prends reprend tout
simplement du fou et mon fou et
magnifiquement placé pour la taxe est
moi qui ai la pièce de plus avec les
blancs on n'a pas encore fait le bilan
on va le faire juste après le dernier
coup des noirs mais j'ai intérêt à
profiter de ma pièce de plus pour avoir
un jeu dynamique donc je t'attaque se
sont créés des menaces et récupérer des
pions si possible alors après damien
fons 17
voilà les noirs on peut considérer qu
ici pardon on peut considérer qu ici les
noirs ont fini leur combinaison de début
de partie il faut faire un bilan
ils ont donné une pièce ce fameux fou
proche de bon on avait gagné un pion au
passage mais pas que on a aussi aimé
jouer ces cinq s'éprend des quatre vingt
gamins deuxième pion alors quand on les
pions un deux trois quatre pions pour
les blancs et 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 pour les
noirs donc pour la pièce les noirs ont
trois pions ce qui en général est
considéré comme valoir une pièce légère
donc on peut considérer qu au niveau
matériel
ça peut être équilibré
quand même un petit avantage des blancs
dans cette cette situation c'est qu'ils
ont ils ont quand même la paire de fou
bon dans une position qui semble quand
même plus ou moins ouvertes donc en
faveur de la paire de fou donc ça c'est
que ça peut être un léger avantage pour
les blancs mais contrebalance ce
résultat la position ici du roi blanc
qui pas non plus c'est vrai très très
sécure il n'est pas très en sécurité ce
roi blanc compario roi noir qui a l'air
d'avoir beaucoup plus depuis en neuf ans
bien sûr c'est un peu plus en l'air mais
c'est pas les noirs qui vont pouvoir
vraiment attaqué avec une pièce de moins
bon donc c'est la non à la pollution et
noir et surtout extrêmement
positionnelle et le fait de tenir le
centre regarder un bocal et centrale
avec une belle diagonale et une position
extrêmement solide
trois pions pour contrer une pièce un
jeu asymétrique ceci dit c'est sans
doute une bonne une bonne ouverture pour
pogo nina la russe qui doit essayer de
gagner cette partie et vaut mieux ce
type de position peu compliqué avec du
matériel asymétrique une pièce pour
trois pions et qui donne des chances de
gains tout à fait intéressante donc
falls 3 voilà pour ça c'est l'idée qu'on
a une idée si on a un peu joué ces trois
là et le cavalier est attaquée mais bon
le décès était protégé par la dame
on ne peut pas de danger particulier et
on prend un biais donateurs fou prend
hélas les blancs sont pas mécontents ils
ont un très joli fou qui vise le pion g7
des noix donc une belle position
autre désavantage quand même pour les
blancs à parce qu'on a cité la le fait
que l'euro ait un peu en l'air mais ce
cavalier l'aï quand même hors jeu pour
l'instant et l'activé pas simple si je
passe par f2 je me prends en cavale et
j'ai trois échecs et gagne en qualité
si je viens j'ai un bail je suis pas
actif en juin il va falloir que j'aille
ans d'abord en e2 avant de pouvoir
attaquer par l'est au centre entre d4
qui est pas une la case
mieux ces cavaliers en amont rien qui
soit en scène coin s'ils pouvaient 35 ça
serait vraiment idéal enfin on voit bien
que voilà ce cavalier quand même cette
pièce de plus finalement est un peu hors
jeu les deux dames ces deux très
intéressant cette partie avec ce
matériel comme ça la dame ces deux
belges actives la dame sur la deuxième
un même une dame sur la deuxième ça peut
être pénible et puis le four b2 et
attaquer donc ça oblige la réponse
blanche
il va falloir faire quelque chose pour
ce fou donc simplement les blancs
choisissent de prendre en quatre prises
avec quatre bons cas de prise du fou je
prends mes sept oncles à celle hors de
question donc simplement fou prend
maintenant tour f2 voilà le cavalier qui
était 1,4 empêcher la tour devenir en f2
donc on les élimine
et maintenant on joue tours l2 mais ce
faisant on a donné la paire de fou mais
il était fort ce cavalier on voit bien
que voilà la position noir obligé
quasiment cette dame d'être ans
alors ici position n'est pas simple ce
qu'on peut jouer un coup comme tour d un
oui bien sûr on aurait pu activer la
touriste y regarder en d1 on se dit
c'est bon mais non regard des problèmes
il ya une menace noir regardez c'est que
le fou ici clou le pion g2 donc
simplement là on peut faire dame proche
trois échecs ça c'est un piège qu'il
fallait signaler en jouant ici surtout
wave ii d'amd 3 les noirs menace de
prendre ce fameux cavaliers qui est un
peu fait d'où l'important voyez d'avoir
ces grandes diagonales comme ça avec le
roi qui est derrière il ya des clous
âgées ça peut être intéressant donc les
blancs se laisse pas faire i sort du
club qui plus est m leroy sur une case
noire plus jamais être embêté par le
foot case blanche
c'est un bon et maintenant mais les
normands profitent tous rêvent dé 8
voilà on interdit de venir chasser la
dame donc on a pris la colonne des avec
une position centrale toujours forte en
fou et 4 extrêmement puissant bien placé
sur une diagonale magnifique et blanc
toujours une pièce de plus mais une
pièce de plus qui est inactive contre
eux des pions noirs et notamment ici un
peu noté sur l'ale ici deux pions
contraint possibilité pour et noir de ce
crime qui ont passé attention forrest
est quand même extrêmement prudent et on
voit pas comment les blancs peuvent
monter une attaque en tout cas prendre
ils ont pas su pour l'instant montré
qu'ils avaient un plan pour monter une
attaque contre le roi pour mettre en
valeur leurs pièces de plus donc tour c1
puisque je peux pas aller sur des 1
julien sur ses seins et les noirs
s'opposent sur la colonne s'est
tranquillement en mettant en jeu leur
dernière pièce la torah 8
pas de problème pour prendre en un
échange
hélas les blancs jouent un coup sans
doute un peu faiblard puisqu'il aurait
pu essayer
peut-être ici de jouer un coup du type
tour d2 voire peut-être tour deux
peut-être pour attaquer le fou mais
tours d2 c'est bien pour attaquer la
dame et surtout pour mettre en jeu le
cavalier imaginons ici par exemple tour
des deux attaques la dame que font les
noirs ici avec un joli coup noir
imaginons que la dame s'en aille par
exemple si la dame vient b1 par exemple
pourrait attaquer la dame blanche
c'est faisable mais je joue par exemple
dame e3 très certainement et le cavalier
h3 va venir maintenant en f2 et le foot
obligé de partir et surtout j'ai
commencé à activer mon cavalier
voilà donc à venir entre englos si le
but voilà le but de cette manoeuvre
c'est deux tactiles et me regarder les
noirs en contre jeu magnifique sur tour
des deux tours ces deux incroyables
sacrifice de dames
ça c'est fou attaque la tour blanche si
les noms les blancs prennent la dame
détroit c'est tout à fait possible
simplement pour tout reproche et 2 le
roi est obligé de venir un chat n'y a
pas d'autres coûts et regardez c'est
magique tour aux deux et en os de nos
sommes achats tacle adam méjean pêche en
plus la dame de prend le fou qui fait
échec
là il faut que les noirs les blancs
pardon joue le forcer
roger 1 simplement maintenant tour
prendre dame
bilan des courses j'ai gagné encore en
pions mais non j'ai quatre pions pour la
pièce et je peux même envisagé de
rentrer dans la finale deux tours après
rend f2 fou prend reprend 4 pions pour
la pièce c'est les blancs qui ont lutté
pour la nul malgré leur pièce de plus
ses deux pions sont vraiment beaucoup
trop faible ils ont aucune aucune
possibilité d'aider les pièces blanches
ils sont complètement dominé par les
pierres noires les points noirs vont
essayer de mettre en jeu leurs pions et
c'est eux qui jouent pour le gain donc
vous voyez que c'est quand même une
position une ouverture tout à fait
intéressante pour les noirs cette
histoire là
donc après tout reprendre tout reprend
bel et bien jouer un coup bon mais c'est
pas évident mais que son tour d2 à tour
ces deux mais joue un coup quand même
peu faiblard même très faible en a trois
bon alors le petit intérêt de ce coup
c'est de mettre le pion sur cases noires
donc il n'est pas attaquable par le fou
enfin bon on voit bien que ce coup quand
même c'est pas c'est pas terrible
terrible fou des scènes quand même pour
les noirs bon il ya plus rien à taper 1
à 2 simplement je le fous sur une belle
case centrale en d5 où il est protégé
dans le pion aux 6 et donc il est moins
en l'air entre guillemets que s'il avait
été en a eu quatre se joue alors les
noirs aurait pu envisager ici d'autres
coups comme tout simplement tour ces
deux aussi pour échanger les tours et
puis on voit bien que c'est la pièce de
puces des noix et est tout à fait des
blancs par dans est tout à fait relative
à cause des pions en plus sans la bombe
est fou dessins que c'est pas si mal
mais tournée de maintenant tourner deux
faut que la dame boul dame g6 d'alger
six attaques le pion g2 donc cavalier f2
qui semble quand même la meilleure façon
d'activer le câliner pas possible
puisqu'il y aurait simplement dans le
plonger de maths il faut pas se tromper
les blancs ici ils ne peuvent pas
vraiment active est localisé à moins de
le mettre en juin mais en juin après un
f3 et valier va sans doute se rend fou
prend avec un doublement des pions et
s'il vient à eux deux c'est pareil est
toujours une menace en g2 ce cas il y a
du mal à s'activer toujours dans le cinq
pourquoi pas la dame créer une petite
batterie ça mange pas de pain ni l'autre
sur g7 avec food and hell arabes ont les
noirs tranquillement jouissent chasse la
dame et en plus ce jeudi définitivement
à ce fou blanc on regarde y'a un mur là
il ya un petit mur tu passeras jamais tu
peux rentrer à la maison
dans le 3 il a les noirs maintenant
peuvent activer leur tour très joli tour
c4 tranquillement je viens sur la
quatrième voilà je fais pression sur les
caisses du centre j'ai activé matour sur
la fois présent sur la colonne c est sur
la quatrième c'est tout est
magnifiquement placé d'autant que les
surfaces blanches
donc on voit pas bien comment les blancs
pour l attaque et si ce n'est toujours
pareil avec ce qu a aller mais par où
c'est pas clair
ça serait beaucoup trop long tous rêvent
de retrouver de la menace c'est un peu
simpliste l'an passé ça existe c'est f5
attaque la dame et le pion aux six pour
enlever la défense de ce fou en cas de
prise et bien le fou est simplement hors
jeu ça permettrait une aventure de type
cavaliers f4 attaque la dame et le fou
ce genre de manoeuvres damev cinglé nord
ne laisse pas faire simplement une block
le pion par la dame et la foux c3 les
blancs empêche aussi les noirs d'avancer
leurs pions ce qui pouvait commencer à
les titiller parce que la tour
maintenant qu'ils sont en 4e peut aider
à une manoeuvre de type a5b 4 protégeant
le pion b4 tour à quatre voies la voir
le fou en b3 n'empêche pas la tour
devenir 1 à 4 sur fouquet catégorie à 5
probablement et le fou est obligé
d'aller on ne sait où
en n'étant pas protégé donc il n'y a pas
beaucoup de casse pour ce fou fou des
deux je protège le pion à 3 par l'adam
voilà en enlevant le fou c'est une
défense latérale mais voyez que les
pièces blanches restent faibles voilà le
cavalier toujours pas rentré en jeu et
pour hors-jeu en fait c'est comme si on
jouait sans et se fout bon il était bien
placé en b2 vers le roi mais maintenant
regardez comme il est piteux ici en d2
il défend le f4 bronca pas besoin d'être
défendu toutes les pièces le défendre se
fera vers le plan qui est hyper défendu
et bron il a un petit oeil de ce côté là
mais bon ça va pas trop gêner les noirs
au vernet à 5
voilà donc les noms ars et les noirs
curieusement qui ont une pièce de moins
et qui sont le plus libre de jouer des
coups dynamique des coûts positionnelle
aussi des coups d'attaqué coup de ici de
débordement pour essayer de créer un
pion passé et pourquoi pas tenter de
gagner la partie
incroyable cette ouverture on donne une
pièce dame ccnq attaque b5 attention est
là simplement très jolie simple fort dam
des trois dames s'incruste dans le camp
blanc défendent b5
phocéen ayant plus donc le pion à 3 été
attaqué à issy dames et tours 1 contre
le camp en fout c'est un ici est presque
forcé les pouces et un protège tout ça
alors à noter ici que tour c4 ne
marcherait pas parce que simplement on
pourrait prendre
on pourrait sans doute reprendre b5 mais
simplement les noirs n'ont pas peur
regard des dames ces cas il s'échange
même des pièces c'est aussi un signe et
ça quand on échange des pièces en
général c'est qu'on se sent mieux en
finale est en effet celui maintenant qui
semble jouer pour le gain c'est les
noirs cpeq extraordinaire d'un prend
tout reprend deux pions ici
potentiellement une fois qu'ils auront
poussé gm puis on passe et de ce côté un
cavalier toujours or je m'en fous est
très fort et puis là de toute façon j'ai
capian contre 2 donc je me dis même si
j'ai une pièce de moins je risque pas
grand chose il suffira d'éliminer ses
deux pions et la finale sera nulle même
avec une pièce de plus on mate pas fou
b2b 4 apprend tout reprend
alors tout reprend eux
on garde le pion passé on aurait pu
prendre du pillon apprendront si c'était
possible c'est possible de prendre du
plomb un bon je préfère prendre avec la
tour pourquoi pas parce que sans doute
elle veut garder le pion passé ici aussi
loin que possible de l'action oblige les
blancs à mettre des pièces loin de leroy
bon c'est une possibilité mais apprendre
mais peut-être mieux parce que bon c'est
délicat
mais ce pion quand même or à en
apprendre et il aura une caisse de
promotion socas blanche donc une case
qu'on peut protéger avec le fou alors
que là ce pion à n'a pas de 15 sa case
promotion n'est pas protégé par le fou
donc plus dur d'avancer le pion à dame /
à queue sur b semble-t-il bon donc à
prendre mais quatre donc tour en d4
montrait bien simplement fous ces trois
attaques la tour et le pion par
transparence tomber cinq tours d2 à
bombay j'active la tour maintenant et
puis je libère encore une fois la kz2
pour le cavalier éventuellement et puis
je peux menaces et des coups comme f5 et
le pion aux six ne peut pas prendre
puisque le fou pourrait être en prison
là il est défendu par la tourner mais ça
peut être un thème plus tard voilà et là
j'ai libéré j'ai j'ai libéré la kz2 j'ai
activé matour vers le centre à 4 oui on
pousse ses pions passé c'est fait pour
et on sait qu'au reste pas grand chose
d'autant que là le pion et sur blanc
donc on va pouvoir le protégé de toute
façon parfois b3 et ont créé une petite
menace qui peut s'avérer dangereuse à
terme ou b2 empêche le pion d'aller en
a3 tomber trois ans de trois contrôles
la casse b33 menace à trois tout
simplement f5
c'est de casser un peu la position du
fou des scènes qui étouffe un la
position blanche
on aurait pu alors bon là on aurait pu
aussi tenté de
d'activer le cavalier peut-être viager à
eux deux toujours ou via via f2 pour
venir en d3 ou en d3 je ne sais pas un
bon essayer en tout cas de d'activer
toujours cette pièce de plus qui n'avait
joué aucun rôle depuis que les blancs
l'ont donc fcn très bien à 3 tap le fou
donc d4 à bon alors c'est délicat pour
les blés noirs ici si on jouait cinq
attaques le fou le fou desseigne n'est
pas protégé imaginons ce coup c'est
possible simplement prendre et e5 et
après la prise ici par exemple était
simplement prend le foot et sur a2
simplement jouent tour à cinq ce pion
est tenu et enfin le cavalier va pouvoir
jouer un rôle donc ici f 5 à 3
food et 4 1 pour tenter les noirs de
jouer 5 c'est presque un piège mais
simplement tombé 4 alors trouvé 4 2 id11
petit oeil sur le fou ce qui peut être
intéressant parce que ce fou contrôler
la case de promotion de mon pions et 2
je libère l'action du food et cinq sur
la case à 2 voilà donc du coup je vais
pouvoir jouer à deux
et le fou contrôle à deux donc la tour
n'attaque pas vraiment le pion et je
menacerait tout reprendre fou tout
reprend dame d'accord donc ici ouf enfin
enfin ce cavalier vient rentré en jeu en
f4 alors ce cavalier avait joué sur la
case h3 si je me rappelle bien je veux
une remontée pour voir dans les coûts il
ya un grand moment
acta qu il était venu
dès le voilà 19e coup 19e coup et là on
est au 45e donc ça fait vingt six coups
que ce cavalier attendait son heure
26 coup quand on sait qu'une partie
d'échecs dure en moyenne 40 coups c'est
une moyenne
donc 40 coup là on est au 45e donc on a
dépassé la moyenne
ben on voit que ce cavalier quand même
un jouet très très grand nombre de coups
hors jeu et il sans jouer vraiment de
rôle il mena syrien et même
défensivement ni offensivement ni
offensivement qu ils vont me servait à
rien ils étaient aussi actifs comme pion
en maintenant c'est pas pareil il rentre
en jeu et commence à exprimer sa
puissance à 2 à 2 alors la menace noir
c'est de prendre le fou et surtout
reprendre faire dames 1 alors les blancs
ici aurait pu tenter une manoeuvre
intéressante
avaaz de simplement qu on prend aussi ce
très intéressant
puis on prend le 6
hélas les noirs par exemple sur tours
prend des quatre aurait pu se voir
opposer tout reprend on laisse faire
dame qui s'ils ont choisi non pas de
faire cavalier ni fou ni tour mais en
fait à un rappel que la promotion c'est
au choix
et là simplement prendre des 5 et le
pion russie c'est vraiment dangereux
c'est bien aussi si on peut menacer tour
des huit échecs le roi h7 est maintenant
que cette menace dames et il n'y a pas
d'échec contre le roi blanc donc c'est
vraiment très très dangereux cette
position est bon on a touré cavalli
contre dame normalement alors d'armes
contre trouve qu allissa fait nul mais
il reste des pions final pas facile à
voir papa ciel a calculé qu'un pion aux
six très dangereux donc le rêve c'est
une variante possible bon c'est parce
qu'on choisit les joueuses donc à 2
simplement jeu-là signal c'est quelque
chose qu'il fallait estimé du calcul et
ça pour onida très certainement donc là
elle choisit une autre suite qu'elle
estime plus sur cavale et prend des 5es
l'éliminent elle élimine le fou des 5
alors ce faisant le pion à 2,8 emprise
et en plus il peut pas pousser
adam alors c'est ça l'idée blanc c'est
de forcer quasiment l'entrée en finale
qui va suivre les noirs prennent le fou
on prend le pouls des 4 et donc on
menace de faire dame donc les blancs
peuvent pas vraiment prendre ici en plus
c'est pas pareil que celle qu'on vient
de voir puisque en cas de prise dames la
tourette attaquer donc il n'y a pas le
temps de faire plus on prend 1,6
donc tout reprend des cartes n'y a pas
trop le choix pour les blancs faut
prendre à deux mais on peut faire un
petit coup intermédiaires qu'il faut
faire de façon quasi si là aussi il
fallait bien calculer on fait d'abord
cavaliers price is échec pourquoi ben on
va quand même prendre un pion au passage
c'est pas plus mal
g prend et maintenant 3 2 voilà alors là
bilan des courses c'est au noir de jouer
et on voit bien qu'ils sortent de cette
passe d'armes toujours avec un avantage
trois pions contre 2 qui plus est c'est
à eux de jouer ils pourraient très bien
prendre ce pion il se retrouvait donc
avec deux pions de plus simplement on
est en finale deux tours
ses deux pions de plus malgré le fait
qu'ils aient trois pions deux contre un
il y en a aucun de passer puisque à eux
deux doubles et un qui est là et
regardez ils sont tous face aux pions g2
donc ya pas de pions doublé et c'est
probablement une position nul
quoique il peut y avoir des subtilités 1
c'est extrêmement difficile à analyser
comme ça faut bien faudrait spécialisé
finale deux tours pour savoir vraiment
comment jouer de façon pertinente cette
finale alors elle joue au pogo nina un
coup intéressant quoique discutable que
cinq essais intéressants elle prend pas
le pion parce qu'elle veut pas des pions
doubler la l'estiment que c'est celui
donc pas de chance de gain maintenant
elle sait que je joue pour le gain alors
ce qu'il faut savoir ici c'est que si
les noirs arrivent à prendre ce point f5
et à échanger et qui quand même est
faible parce qu'on voit bien que
difficile de le déjà on peux pas le
défendre par g4 et puis h5 pourrait
empêcher définitivement de venir le
défendre et on pourrait jouer torres
quatre tours prend et ensuite si on
arrive à échanger ce pion à h contre se
plonger avec deux pions liés
ces gagnants c'est sûr on n'en est pas
là et c'est l'idée des noirs c'est de
garder ici des pions mobile et de façon
à pouvoir faire des échanges
si on arrive à les changer ce pion même
contre celui là je suis pas sûr que ses
deux pions contre cela se soit pas aussi
quelque chose de gagnants parce que les
pions sont liés et est énorme un
avantage net
les chances que ça soit lui aussi sur
une très bonne défense
alors ton échec pourquoi pas bref cette
tour échec
regardez ce pion quand même heureusement
qu'il est là il empêche le roi noir de
revenir en jeu donc il est bloqué on est
un peu obligé de rester ici voilà il
faut venir la pinta leurs fonds pour
pouvoir couvrir de la tour voilà on veut
maintenant sur un échec éventuellement
couvrir de la tour et donc se retrouver
en possibilité d'amener le roi vert le
vers le centre et surtout éviter déchets
séché que perpétuelle mais sur qui ça
serait pas une bonne nouvelle
les noirs cherche le gain ici tout
raciste voilà très bien attacked pions
et six à orly l'espoir des blancs s'est
durcie revient à cet échec aura huit
tours est là et on répète et c'est bon
je me sens avec la nulle je m'en sors
bien parce que voilà il faut encore se
battre roanne cette tour échec alors
c'est une idée des blancs t'as qu'à
partir à noter que ici sur un coût qui
comme rodez si ce serait une faute
tout simplement on joue tous rêvent 7 et
voilà le pion aux 6 semble totalement
perdu priscilla aussi va être pris alors
même si on pousse le pion ici parce que
la tour de marion allard était faux faut
être précis comme il faut regarder ça en
détail un sais pas
rose sept tours à cet échec ton 17
empêche sa tour 17
à noter ici que en cas des changes la
finale de pions et gagnante
donc il faut absolument garder les tours
pour les blancs donc rentre pas mais au
final paire d'antennes voilà finale de
roi avec une pointe plus comme ça qui
est passé soutenu voilà c'est pas un
pion seul ses voiles cc gagnant que sauf
dans les rares cas mais là c'est bon
mangez tour à 6,7 projet trois mois g7
alors à noter ici oui ce roi g3 avant
d'aller plus loin
là il y avait un coût très intéressant
pour les non justement parlé juste tout
à l'heure c'est une idée de jouer h5
voilà l'idée d'âge 5 c'est quoi
j'empêche leroy d'allant g4 et même s'il
vient à gstaad je vais lâcher ce pion et
je vais essayer de prendre le plus au
racing donc par exemple ici imaginons
roi h4 alors je peux jouer tour
alors est ce que je fais chèques n'ont
sans doute pas je joue tour d2 d'abord
un jeu j'attaque le pion g2 et si prise
simplement je prends le taux le pion g2
et je vais menacé tour j'ai cinq échecs
et tourcoing f5 là les blancs peuvent
jouer échec pour repousser le roi noir
qui va venir ce cas ci dessous cachés en
1 h 6 au besoin est là sur un coup comme
g4 pour essayer en cas de prise de
reprendre du roi et le roi reste un
petit peu au contact du caillot f5 pas
un coup comme échec simplement moi j'ai
trois et on joue un groupe simple comme
un tour en h1 et ici les noirs menacé
simplement tour j'ai un échec et le pion
on va tomber
alors s'il est si les blancs jouent g5
sans doute
et bien simplement fait encore échec de
la tour on prend de la tour et ce pion
va pas être perdues qui plus on pourra
jouer tour g7 et le roi va sortir par h7
tout simplement est donc ici on s'en
sort bien et là l'idée c'est donc de
d'empêcher les blancs de réunir leurs
pions et de casser il faut si on arrive
à prendre ce problème quand on l'a dit
on a deux pions passé lié donc il faut
éviter par qu'on les pièces les pions se
réunissent donc on échange le pion h
contre le plonger c'est une bonne
affaire donc sur roy g3 qui est un cours
bizarre ici il se range étroit en fait
j'ai quatre est sans doute mieux tout de
suite en fait ici g4 et
là les noirs c'est moins simple si je
joue aux 5,2 sans doute les blancs
peuvent prendre c'est pas la même parce
que de bien bon c'est pas la même partie
d'autant que si on peut essayer quand
même de voir si les signes et noir
jouent h5 ici je peux jouer puis on
prend oui on prend un système tout
simplement voilà et là c'est plus dur là
c'est plus dur parce que si je joue rage
et 7h six échecs et je peux pas prendre
à cause de tout reprend m6 voilà si je
m'en vais c'est pas la même c'est pas la
même partie le pion achille est pas pris
donc il peut pousser avec des amis des
menaces voilées c'est subtil 1 jusqu'au
bout alors roy jetteront passe devant
pions et h5 semblait être ici un très
très bon coup bon les noirs ne le voit
pas il jouera g73 g4 c'est la même
excellent idée quand même tours 7
bon alors voilà l'idée des noirs je mets
la tour derrière le pion passé ce qui
est souvent pour pas dire tout le temps
excellente idée
la torre temps derrière est très
difficile d'arrêter ce pion qui va
avancer il faut essayer de longs
métrages et de bloquer une tour pour ça
donc la voie la torah 3 en cas de cas
d'avancée du pion maintenant simplement
jeu le bloc et après j'irai le prendre
avec roy f4 tout reprend et peut-être là
la finale est nul car wash sets 3-6
attaque et 6e quatre tours à deux pour
eu maintenant bloquer le pion en e2 e3
tours 2 ce plan est perdue puisque je
vais pouvoir à tout moment d'un
dangereux f3 tour prend et on a plus
possibilité de prendre le pion f5 avec
des pions liés voici j'élimine ce pion
c'est probablement nulle déjà parce
qu'il ya plus de pions liés on va
détailler après tour j'ai cet échec
croix h4 sachant que 3 et toujours en
prise dont g 8 g 4 pour les blancs touré
8 protège 3g 3 et maintenant hcm voyez
que les noirs finalement je joue quand
même à stein mais là c'est pas la même
position avec tout à l'heure c'était
quand même beaucoup plus avantageux pour
les noirs là elle y étant prises etc
voilà d'ailleurs les blancs sont prises
se prive pas une traîne 11,5 et après
roy h 6 3 f 4 tours 5
tout reprendre 3 c'est fini 1 la
position ici après tout reprendre trois
rois prendre trois rois princes cinq
héros f4 et déclarées nulles les nord
peuvent prendre le pion est simple vous
allez voir ici simplement je joue 3,4 et
blanc sont jaloux et wife trois ou
quatre c'est pareil je jouerai g5 et ce
roi 4 simplement je joue roger 4 est
remuée simplement roi de 3,3 prend 1,5
et l'ag ouf
au dernier moment l'opposition ont
heureusement que le pinot noir n'est pas
f c est parce que là si c'était un
honneur de jouer avec le plan esthétique
jour et f6 ça serait au blanc de jouer
et les noirs seraient gagnants mais là
c'est au noir de jouer et si le noir
joue simplement ensuite s'il revient on
suit et cette finale est nul puisque
pour gagner les finales de pions roi
contre roy il faut que le roi certes
passe devant le pion mais gagner
l'opposition enlacés au nord de jouer et
non pas aux blancs voilà si c'était au
blanc on prendrait par exemple ici si
les blancs venus angers 3 ans prendrait
l'opposition ont fait en gagnerait du
terrain en jouant trois ou quatre et
petit à petit on prépare le chemin du
pion avant de bouger le pion voilà sinon
à la fin ça fait nul alors à noter un
pour revenir donc ici la partie est nul
finalement donc finale de pions nul
après rolf 4 allée jouer se connaissent
très bien c'est cette position
le fonds nul c'est vraiment une mule
théoriques sans problème mais ici dans
cette position ce que je disais si on
revient avant voilà ton j'ai cet échec
roche 4
si les blancs même avancé même avant que
je voulais voir qu'est ce que vous
voulez voir si tôt 1 6 2 4 3 2 non ça
c'est bon peu 3 1 toro 2 dont j'ai cet
échec à heroes h4h 4 je pense moi que
roy f3 aurait suffi probablement
voilà c'est ce que je voulais dire
puisque sur tours g5 qui gagne le pion
f5
simplement on peut jouer g4 et sur h 5
qui il va gagner là aussi on veut bien
nous sans doute ou simplement prendre
cinq tours prend
3g 2 par exemple j'ai trois ans c'est
pareil tout est nul en fait ici tôt pour
le savoir la tour prend 1,3 ce que je
voulais vous dire ici c'est qu'on est
dans une position voilà c'est ça je
voulais montrer trois pions et tour
contre roy et tour c'est un peu pareil
que rond et pion contreront a finalement
c'est à dire que si le roi blanc et
devint le pire on est bien cette
position ne peut pas y aller par les
nord il suffit que les blancs voilà
reste sur la troisième ici avec la
fameuse position de philidor il met le
roi simplement devant le pion il est
déjà angers travail de lampions il peut
rester là le renard pourra jamais passer
devant la tour et il sera obligé
d'avancer le pion et quand le pion va
arriver sur la troisième et bien après
on enlève la tour sur l'euro et sur la
huitième et ensuite on fait plein échec
et les noirs n'ont plus de quoi se
cacher puisque imaginer le roi blanc là
le pion la bombe il ya le roi ne peut
pas se mettre devant le pion obligé de
mettre la tour en opposition en échange
des tours et la position de la finale et
nous voilà c'est la position de philidor
donc cette position faut le savoir elle
est nulle ce qui permet aux joueuses
justement de savoir dans quelle finale
il faut entrer ou ne pas rentrer voilà
donc une belle partie extrêmement
technique où les noirs sacrifie une
pièce pour trois pions avec quand même
un avantage positionnelle au centre et
qui ont failli jouer pour le gain et
mariam use it shoe que n'est pas passé
loin sans doute ici est bien de gagner
le titre dans cette troisième partie et
même dans cette finale deux tours on a
vu que peut-être le coup h5 pour les
noirs peut-être qu'on l'avait vu tout à
l'heure était peut-être déjà ce roi g3
sur cette position
le courage 5 est peut-être déjà un coût
qui donne l'avantagé au noir on va les
prendre le pion 9,5 et blanc peuvent pas
romancier opposé secours g3 semblait un
peu faible belle partie tendue
maintenant l'ukrainienne a toujours
l'avantagé
il reste une partie pour pogo nina pour
revenir ça va pas être facile
puisqu'elle a le noir mais dans l'est
quasiment les
tous les matchs qu'elle a fait
précédemment c'est avec les noirs
qu'elle est revenue dans au score donc
donc tout est possible elle est capable
de sortir une très grosse partie avec
les noirs nathalie bourreau nina est ce
que maria mozy tchouk est capable de
contenir son jeu avec les blancs avec le
stress parce que ça va se jouer
maintenant sur les nerfs les deux
joueuses sont quand même un très haut
niveau sont toutes les deux en finale ça
va jouer le nain sur la pression la
pression du match et du titre de
champion du monde
peut-être plus que sur la technique on
va voir ça on verra ça dans cette
quatrième partie avant d'éventuelles tie
break qui seraient aux mains des
tie-breaks extrêmement terrifiante ans
du titre du champion du monde à la clé
dans les tie-breaks ce serait tout à
fait tout à fait intéressant mais m'est
pénible pour les chevreuse qui qui vont
avoir les nerfs mis à rude épreuve voilà
merci d'avoir suivi pour cette troisième
partie de la finale et à très vite sur
diagonale tv pour la suite de ce
championnat du monde
croire